Mark Zuckerberg was a Harvard freshman
with a gift for computer programming
less than a decade later he is the
baby-faced multi billionaire power
broker who rubbed shoulders with the
president
my name is Barack Obama and I'm the guy
who got mark to wear a jacket and tie I
think most people still haven't really
digested the scale of Facebook or how
quickly it's grown the goal is obviously
to get to ubiquity I mean Mark
Zuckerberg wants everyone to be on the
surface he transformed a dorm room
project into the internet's biggest
global village the site now has over 900
million users can't underestimate how
driven work Zuckerberg really hits
Zuckerberg is just as visionary as Steve
Jobs he's gonna prove just as
influential as Bill Gates but for all
that success Zuckerberg has confronted
bitter battles and lawsuits over
Facebook's origins one he wanted to
control his own thing and two if he's
gonna go against someone he's gonna
crush them we spent three months working
with mark being essentially let on we
were all blindsided we had no idea that
he's working on a competing product he
is waged an all-out war on his biggest
competitors Facebook and Google's
relationship is pretty simple they just
don't like each other and Zuckerberg has
come under fire for pushing the limits
on user privacy users have less control
over private information they don't
fully know how their information is
being shared he's not dealing with just
a piece of technology he's dealing with
people and their behavior and in many
ways is doing it on the fly they have
amassed this humongous database of
information about us because we trusted
them so the question is should we still
trust them
I think that the goal that we went into
it with wasn't to make an online
community but sort of like a mirror for
the real community that existed in real
life
Mark Zuckerberg we think we know him
because we've seen his life unfold in
the oscar-winning movie The Social
Network the portrait was unsparing a
super geek intense cutthroat brilliant
and socially crippled I don't understand
which part but was it accurate he's
always had friends you know he's a
pretty social guy um I think in the last
time I checked
eight hundred and seventy-nine friends
on Facebook this is the real Mark
Zuckerberg in rarely seen footage shot
at Facebook's first corporate
headquarters by young filmmakers in 2005
what are we celebrating
March got 3 million users 3 million
users and how long's basically been
around not that long a little more than
a year well Zuckerberg pushes the
envelope on user privacy he opted out of
participating in this program in 2004 at
the age of 19 he created Facebook today
the 28 year old CEO has accumulated a
net worth estimated at fifteen point
five billion dollars Marc's mission from
the beginning was about connecting
people and it was clearly based on this
theory that if the world were more
connected it would be a better place but
there's a lot of surprises when you
really dig deep into the story of
Facebook the biggest single surprise is
the peculiar and tenacious personality
of Mark Zuckerberg and to the depth of
his convictions and his consistency
born in 1984 he grew up in the Hudson
River town of Dobbs Ferry a bedroom
community north of New York City David
Kirkpatrick spent two years researching
a book about Zuckerberg and Facebook
called the Facebook effect he comes from
an unbelievably supportive family in
which he's the only son and he has three
sisters so he was kind of the prince and
in fact I think his parents called him
the prince and he was treated
accordingly so this is a guy without any
problem of self-confidence computer
savvy from the start
Zuckerberg taught himself the
complicated computer language C++ and by
ninth grade had created a digital
version of the board game risk
journalist Jose Antonio Vargas
interviewed Zuckerberg for his New
Yorker magazine profile he actually
created a thing called suck net which is
an internal instant messaging system for
the family so the computers could talk
to each other that's kind of a kid he
was when he got sort of tired of his
local high school he decided to go to
Exeter prep school really because he
just wanted more challenge it was at the
exclusive Exeter Academy that Zuckerberg
and his friend Adam D'Angelo created a
music website called synapse it was
intended to anticipate what your
preferences might be and it was very
very popular even before he started
Facebook he was fending off offers from
Microsoft and others to buy synapse for
well over a million dollars like a tech
world version of an all-star athlete
big-name companies wanted to recruit him
right out of Exeter again Zuckerberg was
unimpressed and chose instead to enter
Harvard in 2002 where it wasn't long
before he got himself in trouble
Zuckerberg hacked into the school's
computers to collect images of students
Nicolas Carlson is deputy editor at
Business Insider comm you can sort of
tell that he's a little bit of a
troublemaker he creates something called
Facemash it's the first year and Harvard
and it's a sort of hot-or-not for the
Harvard
and it maintained an entire list of
Harvard students and which ones were the
most attractive ranking them by hotness
Ellen McGurk interviewed Zuckerberg for
Fast Company magazine Facemash worked in
kind of a little bit of a Nikki way it
made people upset obviously people felt
mocked or exposed and it was one of the
first big experiences that mark had with
the privacy issues of the masses under
pressure
Zuckerberg shut down the site the
Harvard administration board charged him
with breaching security violating
copyrights and violating individual
privacy but by then Facemash was a
campus sensation Zuckerberg had seen his
future at the same time getting trouble
for the building this mischievous web
tool he built a mischievous web tool
that was really popular I imagine that
he had a couple of sleepless nights
worrying about how how bad this thing
was going to be was relieved when it all
blew over but was also incredibly
curious about what he could then make
next if you're a genius with genius
friends sitting in a dorm room suddenly
the world looks like a big happy open
place if you can just get into that
database at the time the technology
landscape was changing dramatically
Brad stone is a senior writer at
Bloomberg Businessweek the internet was
it was really a much different world
back in 2004 Friendster really
demonstrates that a social network needs
to have technical chops the site goes
down all the time it's unreliable
myspace also it's full of ads it's very
distracting it also begins to have
technical instability at Harvard
Zuckerberg met classmate and future
business partner Eduardo Saverin author
Ben Mezrich is one of the few to have
interviewed Saverin
about the early days of Facebook Eduardo
met Mark Zuckerberg in an underground
Jewish fraternity the underground scene
at Harvard you know these were not
really fun event these were kind of
strange little social settings really
bad parties mostly all guys and so
Eduardo and Mark met in this scene and
they became friends pretty quickly
because they were both kind of Outsiders
Facemash gods
Zuckerberg noticed by three insiders
upperclassmen building a social
networking site called Harvard
connection Olympic rowers and twins
Cameron and Tyler Winklevoss with
partner Divya Narendra Harvard
connection was an idea that I'd come up
with when I was a junior in college at
the end of 2002 the team had been
building the site for nearly a year two
of their original programmers had moved
on and they desperately needed a new
partner the three of us are not computer
programmers by trade or practice we did
need it an actual programmer to write
the actual hard lines of code and we
thought mark was that guy
the trio reached out to Zuckerberg he
was enthused excited and clearly his his
eyes were letting up what happened next
sparked a furious battle over how
Facebook was actually created the
details unfold in email exchanges
between Zuckerberg and the
harvardconnection team at first
Zuckerberg appeared eager I wrote over
all this stuff he sent and it seems like
it shouldn't take too long to implement
so we can talk about that after I get
all the basic functionality up tomorrow
night then Zuckerberg began to delay the
project December 4th sorry I was
unreachable tonight
I just got about three of your missed
calls I was working on a problem set
December 10th the week has been pretty
busy thus far so I haven't gotten the
chance to do much work on the site or
even think about it really Zuckerberg
was stalling because he was busy working
on a similar social networking site
based on Harvard student directory
called the Facebook he and Saverin
partnered to fund it mark came to him
and said you know you put up a thousand
dollars and will launch this site and
you know there were no contracts these
were just two kids in a dorm room really
but that's where it started writer
nicholas carlson interviewed more than a
dozen people involved in the founding of
Facebook and found instant messages
retrieved from Zuckerberg computer
he said Zuckerberg sent two Saverin
according to Business Insider the i.m
suggests Zuckerberg was deliberately
misleading the Winklevoss twins
things like look at this site that I'm
working on harvardconnection haha they
made a mistake they asked me to do it
for them because I'm working on my own
Facebook we were always under the
impression that mark was working on
harvardconnection comm there was never
an indication from him that he could not
do the work didn't want to do the work
or was working on something identical on
the side called the Facebook when he met
with the Winklevoss brothers the last
time he saw that he probably should tell
them that he's been working on a
competing product
he sort of conferred about it with
friends but in the end he said you know
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna blank them
I'm gonna blank them in the ear on
February 4th 2004 just as he was
expected to complete work on their site
Zuckerberg and his friends instead
launched the Facebook the Winklevoss
brothers and Narendra found out about it
the same way nearly everyone else at
Harvard did it completely blindsided us
we definitely did not expect that Mark
wanted to have control over his own
project he saw that they were onto
something cool the Winklevoss brothers
but he saw that he could do something
cooler
and so one he wanted to control his own
thing and two if he's going to go
against someone he's going to crush them
and that's what he did
Mark Zuckerberg snoo Harvard based
social networking site the Facebook was
mired and controversy from the start
just days after he launched it in
February of 2004 the Winklevoss twins
and Divya Narendra sent him a letter to
cease and desist in a nutshell our
complaint against Mark Zuckerberg is
fraud unjust enrichment and breach of
contract
Zuckerberg responded with a letter
denying any wrongdoing claiming his site
was a separate venture and used none of
the same code the Winklevoss twins and
Narendra would later appeal a 65 million
dollar settlement with Facebook they
lost in federal court but that
settlement could now be worth 200
million dollars but none of the vicious
legal wrangling slowed the incredible
momentum of the Facebook and that's why
my roommates were kind of like you know
this is pretty cool like I thought this
would work at other schools so we
launched it at Columbia Yale and
Stanford the end within a couple of
weeks each of those three schools also
like had thousands of users who are like
alright this is pretty sweet like let's
just all out see how many schools we can
launch the status group as possible
about this point in time they started to
take meetings with venture capitalists
and with bigger advertisers and this is
all kind of Eduardo's doing they got a
pretty early deal with Visa and they had
a deal with American Express they had a
number of advertisers that came and went
then record companies started getting
interested and they began to get some
pretty good revenue from the music
industry enter Sean Parker who had his
own connection to the music business on
a trip to New York Zuckerberg and his
partner Eduardo Saverin had dinner with
a 24 year old co-founder of Napster the
seasoned entrepreneur and a truly
creative individual extraordinarily
interesting person who had worked his
way into a network in the valley that is
just to die for it particularly at that
point for Zuckerberg Parker was a hero
and a role model partner Saverin
didn't agree Eduardo did not think hi
leave Shawn from the very beginning he
thought that Shawn was a snake oil
salesman that they didn't need Shawn
that Shawn talked a big game but with
living out of a duffle bag and had been
kicked out of two companies in the
summer of 2004 with Saverin remaining on
the East Coast
Zuckerberg left Harvard we came out
hello Alto for the summer just hanging
out because Palo Alto is kind of this
mythical place where you know all the
startups come crowded government to
launch in another 150 schools from the
year started one of the things that mark
did that was very smart by going to Palo
Alto was to actually enter the petri
dish of entrepreneurial ISM particularly
for new technologies Zuckerberg and his
friends moved into a large frame house
with a swimming pool and he reconnected
with Shawn Parker who later became
Zuckerberg roommate he was the adult
supervision he's the guy who showed them
how things are done in Silicon Valley
he's the one who showed them how to meet
investors how to negotiate with them who
to hire Marcus told me stories of just
all of the guys coding late at night
around dining room tables in eating
chicken McNuggets and cereal and there's
partying going on Sean Parker's bringing
them around to the different kind of
cool Silicon Valley hotspots and
meanwhile all the website is growing
astronomically fast I mean there's a
million member party by December of that
year during this time Parker gave
Zuckerberg some shrewd advice he took to
heart he sort of looked at him and said
you need to be the founder of this thing
and you need to be the CEO forever you
know you can't turn this over to
investors and Mark is able to negotiate
a series of increasingly important
investment deals that do two things one
allow him enough operating cash to hire
some of the smartest engineers in the
business and to help him retain majority
control in the company but tensions
began to grow with Zuckerberg original
partner Eduardo Saverin who remained on
the East Coast
Eduardo felt that you know he was the
business head of the company and he was
no longer being treated that way you
know mark and Shawn were taking meetings
all over California they were meeting
with venture capitalists and they were
kind of ignoring it wardo he retaliated
at
froze the bank accounts to try and get
Marc's attention and mark and Shawn
began to sort of figure out a way to
build the company without Eduardo
Zuckerberg responded and froze Saverin
out the duardo was removed from the
company masthead and he essentially
became a nonentity he became a
non-person he was thrown out and he
became very upset
Facebook had a million active users on
college campuses nationwide and big
money was starting to pour in Sean
Parker the new president of Facebook
introduced Zuckerberg to Silicon Valley
angel investor Peter Thiel who put five
hundred thousand dollars into the
company then in the spring of 2005 the
venture capital firm accel partners
offered Zuckerberg twelve point seven
million dollars for an eleven percent
stake in the company and didn't ask for
much control at all walking away from
that investment mark controlled three
out of five board seats which is a
bizarre and unprecedented situation to
have one individual have absolute
effectively dictatorial control over the
disposition and direction of an
increasingly giant company overnight the
Excel investment gave Facebook
evaluation of 100 million dollars as
Facebook's public profile grew so did
Zuckerberg control this time Shawn
Parker was edged out in August of 2005
Parker was arrested for suspicion of
cocaine possession although not formally
charged with a crime and immediately
released it led to his abrupt
resignation as president of Facebook he
was the primary outside face of the
company and it was felt that somebody
who was under any kind of a cloud with
drugs was not the right guy to be the
public face of Facebook
so mark reluctantly agreed that he ought
to leave Facebook was growing with
remarkable speed and Zuckerberg moves
the company from its frat like house
with the pool to a larger and more
conventional space in downtown Palo Alto
3 but the college atmosphere remained
the same one of the things that I do
focus on at Facebook is making sure that
the culture is very friendly you know
and that people hang out in terms of
managing this whole process nothing you
know no like I have no idea what I'm
doing
even their employee interviews were
different chris kelly was brought on in
the new position of chief privacy
officer to deal with facebook's
increasingly contentious privacy issues
at a time when the entire company
numbered only a couple dozen employees
the first time i met mark we we climbed
out on the roof out through the the
window and did our interview on the roof
of what was then a world raps and it was
clear he was young but he had a very
sophisticated understanding of what had
happened so far and where he wanted to
take the company determined to keep
facebook's unusual creative culture
alive all night hackathons were one way
to do it
we have these hackathons that the
company write work basically everyone
gets together and just hacks on
something and build something all night
long and the only the only rule is that
you aren't allowed to work on it a
hackathon what you work on the rest of
the time so people work on crazy stuff
hackathons were some of the most kind of
creative focus that you could ever
imagine in a company imagining these
incredibly talented engineers coming
together for a night and saying we're
going to stay up all night and we're
just going to program and we're going to
we're going to pick a project and we're
going to get it done that night it's
like great make it will prototype it and
there'll be a prototype war and see who
wins it can be a contentious environment
get all the way across from marks point
of view is where good ideas come from
quickly and efficiently good ideas were
flowing zuckerberg then made a change
that would give facebook a sudden and
dramatic boost allowing people to
identify or tag themselves and their
friends in photographs that was a huge
huge change that led to massive new use
of facebook and photos became very
rapidly by far the most used part of
facebook and became the single biggest
driver of its growth that growth
continued in one direction up according
to facebook's internal tracking its user
had shot to 5.5 million users in less
than two years and media giants were
banging on the door in 2006 Yahoo baited
the 22 year old Zuckerberg with an
extraordinary offer a buyout for 1
billion dollars even more extraordinary
Zuckerberg turned them down now if you
are a parent of someone about marks age
you're looking at the yahoo decision and
thinking why did you not take that money
I've never been about money if it was it
would have just sold out we just felt
that doing that and going down that path
would not help us build facebook out to
what we thought it could be in 2006
Mark Zuckerberg rejected a 1 billion
dollar pitch from Yahoo when MTV pushed
the ante even higher Michael J wolf was
CEO of MTV Networks Mark had taken me on
a walk around Palo Alto and show me his
apartment and afterwards we sat down for
a lunch and I told him we'd be willing
to pay as much as a billion and a half
dollars to buy Facebook outright his
answer was I think it's worth a lot more
and besides you've seen my apartment I
don't really need that pun of money and
at the same time I may never have an
idea as good as this one so I'm not that
interested in selling there was internal
strife around it no question there were
a lot of people who wanted to sell
ultimately you know mark decided to turn
down the offers Zuckerberg wasn't ready
to sell because he had some ideas that
he thought would make Facebook even more
popular one of them was called newsfeed
a kind of real-time wire service of
updates about what users were up to
newsfeed is what everybody is doing at
that point or what they're posting what
they're linking to the world that they
live in which is really what a newspaper
is right it's a living breathing
newspaper of people around you but many
Facebook users thought that new
paper sent out too much information and
violated their privacy 750 thousand of
them launched an online protest to say
that it was unpopular at first is a
dramatic understatement they were under
siege at the office they couldn't leave
they were surrounded by news trucks
almost 10% of our user base at the time
joined the students against Facebook
newsfeed group Zuckerberg was forced to
apologize he wrote his apology note
himself it was probably a good learning
experience when Facebook changed some of
the privacy controls that was an
overstep I do think he takes those
seriously but I do think that he's
willing to continue to overstep for the
for the purpose of making a product that
he wants to make the apology was not a
surrender Zuckerberg was sure that users
would get used to this new level of
sharing and he turned out to be right
after tweaking newsfeed it became one of
the most popular elements of the
Facebook experience it just happened
that the first time I ever met mark was
two days after that happened and I can
tell you even though his members were an
open revolt he was not the slightest bit
flustered he had complete confidence
that everything was going to work out
all right Zuckerberg decided it was time
to take facebook beyond its college
roots and introduce it to the general
public
the response was stunning membership
doubled shooting up to 12 million by
2006 Zuckerberg radically altered the
Facebook experience again went for the
first time the 23 year old CEO invited
programmers from around the world to
develop apps for Facebook it was another
turning point expanding Facebook from an
insular world of information to a
platform and it was like the gold rush
now you open up this wonderful platform
and in comes every kind of developer
with every kind of idea from video
sharing to games
the things that blink to things that
turned into you know ballerinas and
hippos and just every kind of fun
wonderful thing the platform companies
or the operating system companies always
do the best I mean think of Microsoft
you know it had this ubiquitous Windows
platform and all these other companies
wrote programs for Windows you know
Facebook's really trying to create
itself in that model and in 2007
Microsoft itself
entered the picture this time with a
deal Zuckerberg couldn't turn down and
for the first time the world got a
glimpse of what Facebook may really be
worth by the time people were finally
giving this the idea that anyone would
pay a billion dollars for Facebook
Microsoft comes along and pays 250
million dollars for 1.6 percent of the
company it was outrageous it valued the
company at fifteen billion dollars
this took Facebook from a thing that a
lot of people use to a thing that
everyone was talking about the 15
billion dollar company but for a 15
billion dollar company Facebook was only
making a meager 30 million dollars in
profits to remedy that Zuckerberg
announced a sweeping new advertising
system in the fall of 2007 one part of
it led companies set up their own
Facebook pages and advertise using
social ads Luke earner covers social
media and own shares in Facebook social
ads on Facebook are ads where they would
say that your friends meg and Ryan like
Virgin America and it turns out not
surprisingly that when you see that your
friends like a product you're more
likely to click on that ad so social ads
have been very successful on Facebook
virtually from the beginning
but another part of Facebook's new
advertising plan beacon gave users far
more than they wanted and they let
Zuckerberg know about it
Zuckerberg made a lot of mistakes the
next mistake which was a really big one
was beacon you go to a third-party
ecommerce site and you buy something and
unless you tell it not to really quickly
it's going to go back and tell all your
friends that you just bought a diamond
engagement ring and obviously you know
that sort of secret revealing can cause
a lot of trouble there was the great
rallying cry that Facebook ruined
Christmas because suddenly everyone's
purchases were being broadcast to their
entire network Zuckerberg really tried
to defend it for a while it took him a
while to realize how wrong it was on
December 5th 2007 Zuckerberg made
another apology he had overreached yet
again but as with previous mistakes it
wouldn't really matter Facebook was just
too popular and it wasn't long before
Zuckerberg was loosening up the
network's privacy controls one more time
more than four years after co-founding
Facebook Zuckerberg still seemed uneasy
in the public spotlight what's your next
finger to do get bought yeah
none of these rumors are true right by
2009 rumors were indeed swirling that
Facebook would go public
instead Zuckerberg took money from a new
investor yuri milner CEO of the russian
internet investment firm Digital Sky
Technologies offered a two hundred
million dollar deal for just 1.9 percent
of the company deals of that size are
kind of never easy there's a lot of
back-and-forth this deal was about the
vision that was shared how big this
company can get everything else was sort
of secondary Milner's investment allowed
Facebook to continue to expand and it
kept the development of the company
firmly in the hands of its founder
Zuckerberg knew that pushing Facebook
advertising even further was the key to
continued growth for years
Zuckerberg believed that Facebook was in
a unique position today even with the
most advanced advertising systems that
exist they only have estimates of what
someone's gender might be or what
someone's age might be or what they
might be interested in but on Facebook
we know exactly what gender someone is
and exactly how old they are and exactly
what they're interested in Jeremy Smith
is chief strategy officer for
SecondMarket a company that brokers
shares and privately held companies
which cannot yet be traded on the public
market
what makes Facebook so desirable from
the perspective of advertisers is that
they are able to accumulate information
on their users like nobody else the
funny thing is the pictures don't really
view it as data its themselves it's
their information it's their lives that
they're putting on there but as far as
advertisers are concerned it is the the
holy grail of data pushing the
boundaries of that holy grail of data
was about to get Zuckerberg in trouble
again in December 2009 he revamped the
privacy settings for Facebook's then
350 million users unless users
individually restored their settings
previously private information was now
available to everyone on the internet
many people just sort of took that
default and somewhat inadvertently
allowed a lot of their information to
become public and many privacy advocates
believe that they didn't explain that or
disclose it sufficiently a firestorm of
complaints from users and consumer
groups forced Zuckerberg to backtrack
again sparking concerns in Congress we
are here today to urge Facebook's
creator and CEO Mark Zuckerberg to
revisit this new policy as soon as
possible we believe Facebook should
reverse its policy to begin exploring
guidelines so users know upfront what's
happened adding fuel to the fire was the
surfacing of still more instant messages
Business Insider published messages they
said showed a friend asking then
college-aged Zuckerberg why people
shared their emails with him
Zuckerberg response was curt and profane
you know I I mean I asked him
point-blank about it and he was very
embarrassed by them by the fact that he
had sent these im's
less than one month later he was put on
a hot seat and a memorably awkward
interview at the all things digital
conference do you feel like you're
violating people's privacy you know
there were real learning points and
turning points along the way in terms of
in terms of building things if I knew
what I knew now then then I hope I
wouldn't have made those mistakes but I
can't go back and change the past I can
only do what we think is the right thing
going forward you know anybody who's
ever kind of doubted what Facebook is
about or want to question his integrity
I mean they can begin it they can keep
pointing back to that right to that
instance of like I can't trust that guy
that is that is going to be our check on
him for as long as he remains CEO you
know and in charge of that company it's
gonna be like okay you're not that guy
we'll prove to us that you're not
Chris hoof Naugle the director of
privacy programs at the University of
California Berkeley believes Mark
Zuckerberg purposefully pushes the
envelope on privacy in most situations
where a company does something that's
unpopular they have blowback they lose
the ability to do something but in
Facebook's case we have something called
I call blow forward where they take two
steps forward there's some type of
public reaction and they just take a
little step back and so over time
they've been able to open up profiles
more and more Marc does not think you
should be a different person at work
than you are at the bowling alley in bed
at school you know he basically thinks
you should be consistent across all
these environments so that's a very
radical view for many older people
you
by the time Mark Zuckerberg turned 25 in
2009 he had accumulated so much
notoriety wealth and power that author
Ben Mezrich had written a book about him
and the founding of Facebook this story
started for me at an email I received
just out of the blue to my website and
Eduardo Saverin was angry he wanted to
tell his story he had co-founded
Facebook with Mark Zuckerberg and he
said had been kicked out of the company
and he felt betrayed and he wanted to
talk Saverin talked to Mezrich for six
months about a lawsuit he filed against
his former Harvard classmate for
diluting Saverin share of the company
according to Mezrich Facebook found out
Eduardo was talking to him and they
essentially settled with Eduardo nobody
knows for sure what happened but what
I've heard is he got 5% of Facebook and
he had to sign an agreement that said he
would never speak to Ben Mezrich again
but Mezrich already had enough material
for his book my proposal had leaked out
on the web
Aaron Sorkin saw it Scott Rudin saw it
so Sorkin immediately signed on to write
the screenplay and everything happened
very quickly from there the pre-release
publicity surrounding the movie also
seemed to force Zuckerberg to go on a PR
offensive the previously press shy Zuka
Berg was suddenly everywhere if you
build something great that's what people
care about when people don't care about
what someone says about you in a movie
he gave Oprah a tour of his house in
2010 and announced on her show a 100
million dollar donation to public
schools in Newark New Jersey 100 million
dollars
the social network opened in wide
release on October 1st 2010 people want
to go on the internet check out their
friends so why not build a website that
offers that friends pictures profiles
I'm talking about taking the entire
social experience of college and putting
it online zuckerberg complained about
his on-screen portrait as a ruthless
socially challenged power geek with no
friends he said there were factual
errors in the script his frame it as if
the whole reason for making Facebook and
building something was because I wanted
to get girls or wanted to get into some
kind of social institution and I mean
the reality for people who know me is
I've actually been dating the same girl
since before I started at Facebook they
just can't wrap their head around the
idea that someone might build something
because they like building things though
he initially said he wouldn't see the
movie Zuckerberg ended up taking his
entire staff to it he even showed up on
Saturday Night Live you ever end up
seeing seeing the film that social yeah
I did cool thanks I and what did you
what do you think it was interesting
I do
the social network won a Golden Globe
Award for Best dramatic picture as well
as three Academy Awards first Tunisia
now Egypt what's next but to an
increasing number of people around the
world Facebook wasn't just a Hollywood
movie it was affecting new life
in late 2010 demonstrators started
taking to the streets in Tunisia and
later in Egypt to protest the repressive
governments by this time more than 70%
of Facebook's half a billion plus users
lived outside the United States in Egypt
one flashpoint for the anger was a case
of police brutality at the center of the
protests was a Google employee ran a
Facebook page well gonna was the manager
in Egypt of a page that was a memorial
to this guy who had been beaten tortured
and killed by the secret police and that
group became very very large many many
hundreds of thousands of members during
the period leading up to the revolt
against Mubarak
Facebook expedited the ability of people
to express their dissatisfaction which
clearly sped up the process of these
revolts the governments of Tunisia and
Egypt fell protesters expressed their
gratitude to Facebook on the streets one
named his newborn daughter Facebook and
Wael Ghonim sang the social networking
sites praises on CNN I want to meet Mark
Zuckerberg one day and thank you
I'm talking on behalf of Egypt this
revolution started on Facebook when
hundreds of thousands of Egyptians
started collaborating content you know
like we would post a video on on
Facebook they would be shared by 50
thousand people on their world within
few hours Facebook itself was was very
quick to try to distance themselves from
that political activity I mean obviously
they supported it but they don't really
want to be seen as a tool of change
because obviously Facebook wants to be
active in regimes like China they don't
necessarily want themselves viewed as a
tool of insurgency Zuckerberg has taken
on a personal goal that might help him
with his mission to connect the world he
says he spends an hour a day studying
Chinese which could potentially help him
gain a billion new friends it's the
fastest-growing and the biggest internet
market in the world there are hundreds
of millions of users and his mission is
incomplete if he's not in China
Mark Zuckerberg power had never been
greater and once again speculation grew
that he would take his company public
despite enormous pressure Zuckerberg has
been hesitant to pull the trigger and
cash in a hundred years two hundred
years from now what's gonna be more
important the money right or the fact
that he has had this kind of impact or
the fact that he's you know executed and
developed and helped evolve this thing
that is more than just a technology site
and it's more than just a website and so
I think that's why it's never been about
money and it's never been about status
when companies go public it's a
tremendous strain on the management and
in fact on top of all of that when you
go public you at you open yourself up to
even greater government scrutiny
aware of that scrutiny Facebook has
amped up their presence in Washington
with a team that includes several former
White House aides and influential
Capitol Hill insiders political official
after a political official will tell you
if you are absent from the debate you're
likely to be the person who kind of gets
cut out and so presence in that debate
particularly when you know Google and
Yahoo and Microsoft and a number of
other very large players are spending a
lot on lobbying as a mistake today
several Facebook founders including
Marc's friends and classmates have left
the company to start new ventures on
their own they've been dubbed the
Facebook mafia but much of Silicon
Valley talent is on their way in top
programmers are leading companies like
Google to be a part of Zuckerberg
momentum and Facebook and Google the two
internet behemoths are competing in
other ways
Ryan's single is a staff writer for
Wired magazine Facebook and Google's
relationship is pretty simple they just
don't like each other they're really I
mean they're competing cultures you know
Facebook was sort of young brash wild
and Google is our you know an algorithm
company like these are guys that like
any problem there's got to be a way that
they can write a little algorithm
that'll fix it it's clear that Google
missed the rise of social and Eric
Schmidt has has admitted to to being a
flat-footed around Facebook and around
social they've tried a number of things
most spectacularly the buzz social
network that just hasn't worked then in
May of 2011 Facebook was embarrassed
when it was revealed that they had
launched a secret attack on Google
Facebook is doing damage control after
revelations it hired a PR firm to plant
negative stories about Google Facebook
claimed publicly it was not a smear
campaign but the exchange revealed just
how vicious the competition has become
the whole burson-marsteller flap was was
really just an in-your-face expression
of the animosity that has sprung up not
only between these two companies but
almost the personal Shakespearean drama
that
playing out between Google and between
Facebook which frankly has a lot of
former Google execs who would like
nothing more than to supplant their
former company you can't underestimate
how driven Mark Zuckerberg really is
he says his mission is to make the world
bar open but her place his mission is
also to be number one right he wants to
be you know inscribed on granite above
bill gates I think he is well on his way
like gates another Harvard dropout
Zuckerberg is a fierce competitor
he moved quickly to vanquish rivals
Google and Twitter with a stunning
acquisition in April 2012 Instagram is
awesome market in an instant
Facebook likes the photo sharing up so
much it's paying 1 billion dollars for
it cash and shares ahead of its IPO but
the app is free and has little known
revenue still Facebook may need
Instagram more than Instagram needs the
money instagram has become a
photo-sharing competitor and a social
network all its own it was considered a
radical and defensive move Facebook
cannot take any chance that any other
social network oriented toward photos
could really get traction that would
come you know compared to theirs and I
think so there's a pre-emptive quality
to this also I think almost certainly
Google was interested and probably maybe
forced Facebook to act now one month
later Facebook finally went public in
the largest IPO on record for an
internet company making Mark Zuckerberg
a multi billionaire this is an awesome
moment the CEO and hoodie and sneakers
retain tight control of his company with
57% of shareholder voting rights
Facebook has literally changed the world
we've moved from the country to the
village to the town to Facebook it's
just getting started - I think it's just
going to get bigger and bigger and
bigger for a site that's able to move
from the dorm room to a site where you
know my 80 year old mother and myself
and my chiropractor and my third grade
class all reunites on the site and we
all have something to talk about
it's an achievement Zuckerberg is just
as visionary as Steve Jobs he's gonna
prove just as influential as Bill Gates
but he's not dealing with a piece of
gadget he's not dealing with some
program he's dealing with our lives he's
dealing with our identity so that's why
I think we're all going to have to kind
of keep him in check in a way we make
decisions at Facebook not optimizing for
you know what is going to happen in the
next year but what's going to set us up
to really be in this world where every
product experience that you have is
social and that's all powered by
Facebook